treat yourself like you matter
talk to yourself like you would your
best friends think about
think about how you talk to other people
you know think about if you're watching
this video if you're a fan of this
channel you are probably
pouring into so many people you're
giving them love you're giving them
encouragement you're giving them belief
you're telling them they can do anything
right your friends even tech even
strangers on social media you're
probably telling them that they can do
things right you're believing in them
you're giving them confidence but then
what happens you go home you look in the
mirror
and you're just telling yourself all the
reasons why you can't do something that
voice inside your own head sucks right
telling yourself that you can't make it
someone like you is never going to do it
we don't treat ourselves with
the same level of compassion empathy
that we have
for other people
you wouldn't talk to your worst enemy
the way that you talk to yourself
that's a big problem i think that needs
to shift it needs to change